we are cleared for landing and gridiron
Heights and welcome back to football
everyone you like that do you like that
we remind you this is a non-smoking
league doing great ice man just gotta
land this bad boy like we've practiced a
thousand times before no problem coach
can you give me a read on the approach
vectors
looks like we're turning from 28 degrees
west headed towards three degrees that's
28 to 3 what's that 28 to 3 and perfect
conditions there's no way you could
screw this landing yeah totally ice you
all right
oh there's one spot starik quarterback
who can land this plane
oh no sorry like a real quarterback
sounds like a jab though smoking chick
and my wife's brother I get this see how
hurt my thumb I'm done
hey guys the new celebration rules are
up yeah we can use the ball as a prop
yeah we could do group dances no way we
can dance on the ground but guys we
still can't do sex moves okay G men
clearly you need me to choreograph our
celebrations now let's show this league
how New York City does dance the river
school hold on maybe I should be the
leader because I'm current yeah and
we're too quick let's go behind the
linemen but they can't see me back here
trust me it's for your protection and
one and two and mcadoo step brightly and
back giant step left and shimmy come on
big blue keep it high and tight nice
Brandon Eli stay in the pocket
okay now kiddo on the Turnpike and
hitchhike left now hitchhike right
come on flowers we need you to get low
bend those knees okay now two-minute
drill let's give them that big Broadway
finish with those jazz hands
let's see those jazz hands jpp
[Music]
last week a tu saksad interception this
week I've had a past offense but I hurt
my groin but then coach did you say how
clever teach I got a run your brother's
here
you know he's raised 37 million dollars
he's a GD angel get it mom I'll never be
as good as JJ well that's the first
problem
trying to be cool start trying to be bad
with the Steelers and were nasty
nacio okay like like Big Ben no no no no
I like that that's nice kid after this
we're gonna buy you some nasty-ass
sweatpants and shoot videos of us doing
700-pound pelvic thrusts TJ what's going
on here get out of here JJ I'm the
nassif stealer boy now you were a lot
and Watts do not upset to do so sorry
I'm not perfect JJ maybe because around
you I feel like the forgotten why well
now hold on who tell you
I'm Derek why and I play fullback on the
Chargers in Los Angeles so check your
wot privilege so sorry
okay Jags great win I miss confused as
you are but I think it has something to
do with being outside the country so
I've arranged that my next game even
further it's gonna be on the moon Wow
well we get there the moon's like a
whole nother planet I figured out how to
win two Super Bowls with Eli Manning I
think I could figure out how to get a
football team to outer space Leonard as
a human science major at LSU I've been
tasked with designing our spaceship I
present to you go for the rocket okay
Blake the controls are based on your
awkward throwing motion so there's only
a 58 percent chance that this journey
ends in the completion McCowan's over
there what are we to judge feride the
ship is calibrated for garbage time all
right do this now we can bring in a real
QB improving veteran who spin to the
playoffs
I'll give you Brian NASA
you
ah the quarter season carnival my
favorite time of year but what about the
playoffs oh Kareem as a game manager on
the Chiefs I've learned to appreciate
the little things like a long
incremental drive that ends in a field
goal or being at the top of the week for
Power Rankings a pride up step right up
what a prize just by making it to the
two-minute warning with one timeout it
is on times yours fellas
time time time out boss I won again dad
ome coach step right up and I'll guess
your weight within 5 pounds oh great
great great great that's ok though oh
when will Gronk die John 92069 nice
you
it was a Tuesday after an ugly win and I
was flying higher than coach first her
before Noelle meeting that's when he
walked in fresh off his first win he was
six foot five with a bullet eye and a
face that was downright punchable I want
to report missing persons who's missing
the Los Angeles football fans damn where
were all those LA Chargers fans
kidnapped dead watching preseason Lonzo
ball I wasn't sure but I knew who I
wanted to talk to someone who actually
had fans that dinky stadium mr. Wentz
where'd you get all those fans in her
leg I don't know North Dakota check the
wagon sue it's clean
just some Bibles and the other Kelsie
let's bring him in for question what
looks like he eluded the sack kid
reminds me the young me if I ever had
passion for the game where to now it's
LA there's got to be football fans some
way I think I've got our next move
I give up
yes one four nine I win welcome to the
party Kaiser you must be our newest
release the upside-down
it's the upside for house what can I do
for your kids I friend Jean Kaiser has
drafted to the outside bounce everything
is bad I'm sorry I'd love to help but I
got a broken collarbone I'm afraid
you're on your own
this place is giving me the creeps only
spoiled drafty
it's called McCoy I'm Cody Kessler buddy
I get it
it's got New York Jew on the Raider
isn't a cold oh that's a great sack
great bike though
Aaron Rodgers you came back and saved us
I always do
I got a quarterback option with elite
sauce lead sauce that that's me I'm Ally
here you go that was really fast he must
be exhausted
yeah I'm saving up to go back to college
hey Joe come sit with us we were just
discussing 6-yard check downs listen
guys no offense but I'm a little bit
more than a game manager I'm gonna go
sit over there
come on hi I'd like to apply for an
elite QB club card okay great just a
couple questions to see if you qualify
so have you started in any Super Bowl
yes and did you win yep
oh and I was also an MVP so and was that
league or Super Bowl okay
I was also 2008 Rookie of the Year
that's great that's awesome all right so
have you ever thrown for more than four
thousand yards in a season I have and
how many times once one oh wow hey the
rest of your stats just popped a break
here technology right mmm nice 2012
season fantasy ownership 14% bikes hey
you know what let's just hit submit oh
sorry Natalie
you
oh man it's bill bell
oh cool Super Bowl rings hey guys look
I'm Bill Russell Wilson Dimas what were
you doing get back here come on man it's
just a little QB sleep you guys I don't
know about this
do you believe how easy was a sneak in
here no it's like getting three
offensive line whoa check it out what
he's got a clone army Gronk's no wonder
he's playing every week Goodell needs to
know about this show I intercept them
mr. Bilchik yes ma'am what is all this
[Music]
you see tom is getting all the needs
extra protections genius he could take
stabs from shotgun and still be under
center you've gone too far belcheck too
bad there's and nobody who can stop me
oh there you guys are
sorry I'm late I took a lot of sacks oh
my kryptonite ooh I am at a
it's not gonna be the same here without
you Bridgewater will be watching when
four-bath pulls of Walsh in the
wild-card see you on the field soon
teddy
Andrew uh nobody has any idea what's
wrong with you or if you'll even play
again that's okay
[Music]
dear fellows I can't believe how fast
things moved on the outside seems like
the world when it got itself in one big
hurry up offense I saw up touchdown
celebration once when I was a kid
but now they everywhere I was 22 then
I'm 24 now I remember when Los Angeles
was just the place teams threatened to
move to now they got a team in a half
and nobody seems to care
some days I think I should just take a
cheap shot from Fletcher Cox oh they'll
send me home to the air but just when I
thought the league and asked me back I
realized some things never change
Jamis is this really the best time for
her Cruz come on Mike it'll be fun we'll
just relax eat some dub use
welcome aboard I'm captain man McAdoo
Ben McAdoo whatever wait a second oh no
this is a cruise ship it's uh that's a
bow
[Music]
it's not so bad the street crab legs
coach I think we're headed for
elimination is Eli's fault mother [ __ ]
jack draw me like one of your zone blitz
says mr. Davis I think we should abandon
ship I love abandoning places this is
not your fault I miss you so much
welcome to the gridiron heights
Thanksgiving Day Parade great to be here
first up Philadelphia Eagles riding an
easy schedule to first place and here
come the Rams of Los Angeles look at
their one fan what a cute kid pretty
sure that's their coach Tony and here's
the bells off to a promising start okay
al I've seen this before you'll notice
by the buffaloes expression the bills
are gonna get shaky start going up and
down and then fully implode Romo you
called it again welcome back the
Patriots are cleaning up the AFC East
again and here's the Titans with mortice
Mariota and Eric Decker or maybe move
out there takers of the Titans and
there's Phillip Rivers I don't think he
knows he's in a parade al was a freaking
LA traffic Gustin here comes the Packers
flow but we're just gonna show you a man
Rodgers watching the Packers flow sad
but still interested in his teammates
great board oh no Tony the balloon in
its head it's heading in for evaluation
oh good he's cleared I mean you gotta
let the balloons play and here comes the
49ers in a celebration of their one win
you
give it my leg for that catch it was a
catch we should have four wins hmm screw
it it's time I take this to challenge
Court okay press eight receivers in
corners of the jury exhibit a not as mr.
Miller but gain full control
okay now technically the rule states
that an order for a football move but
now they changed I need to be 2 feet in
big question what is the ground motion
he never became a runner so therefore
not a catch man what the [ __ ] does that
mean
I kid it is no I'm not some Hot Shot TV
ref I'm a man of the people so my first
one this is 100 guys at a bar gentlemen
was that a can oh yeah that's a cat does
not fall catches the cone jewelry have
you come to a decision yeah we've
decided we have no idea what it catches
in that case the NFL defaults to the
less fun option no catch all right next
up Jerry Jones for treason you were sent
to watch football
those guys
all right guys gather around time for
the week fourteen playoff picture hey
baby what do you like better
Gucci steampunk waka prep-school boy
with a secret I don't know they both
look pretty stupid
Antonia kill me with my toppy tail hey
how do I look
be honest you know blue average
serviceable I guess but what are you
gonna do at this born dub do okay Alex
Smith move a little further to your left
further further it's perfect
[Music]
okay guys enough silly photos long shots
out let's get the real playoff teams
back in here
Xavier Rhodes can you go a little to
your right you're covering Julio damn
right I excuse me am I even in this
thing no not really
okay on three everyone let's say the
Jags really hey nah uh-uh bills guy you
get up just five quick picks will you
just sit next to the other bench
quarterbacks Eli we're the same at kill
me
okay almost done let's just do realistic
contenders only so Titans you're out
Jags out what Lions definitely out and
smile
you told me he was out for the season
broke his collarbone on a sack to stay
farm dog no man could come back from
that this is not a man we were talking
about this is Aaron Rodgers he didn't
finish the job
god help the NFC mr. Rodgers welcome
back to the elite hotel
you're Peter Rogers you're back how many
years has it been seven weeks I'm coming
for you coming for the wild huh ah Hotel
rules can't hit a QB in a penny you here
on business peppers afraid so old friend
highly improbable route to the playoffs
why is he doing this because he's Baba
Yaga the bookie here
you
fifteen years and these lights still
work yeah let me show you how to light
it up yeah let's just take this one week
at a time I think things will turn
around this Christmas no no he wants a
ps4 how about a ps4 ps4
I thought the Seahawks were like injured
or terrible kids all alone in there
let's sacrament take the NFC West they
thought it the Seahawks are going to the
Super Bowl wait a minute I'm a
professional quarterback this doesn't
affect me thirsty for more whip mm you
got no football team distraction
you
I live in the quarterback film room at 1
Gillette Stadium my name is Tom Brady
I'm 40 years old I believe in taking
care of myself
Canha self branded diet and achieving
sustained peak performance in the
morning if my face is a little puffy
I'll put on an ice pack modified with my
$200 smartphone app that combines vague
inspirational quotes with brain games
meant for old people
I'll then apply anti-aging organic I
black made from the ashes of Jimmy
Garoppolo contract extension
Gisele was wrong one day I will throw
and catch the babe I work in the
National Football League
let's see Rodgers card oh my God look at
that subtle mobility Tom are you ok I
have all the characteristics of a human
being
but not a single clear identifiable
emotion I bet your floors covered with
the new favors of your Super Bowl bosses
besides kill kill pal
hey yeah I'm 2017 kind of got away from
me but this is the year that I really
want to get in shape you came to the
right place first thing what's your diet
been like late I mean I've only been in
dub use well sometimes I have a know
before bed maybe in the morning or
during prime time okay sign here wait
with all the other eliminated players
who decided to join a gym on January 2nd
I'm gonna make some changes in 2018 yeah
we're gonna make some changes to this is
where all the cardio goes down how does
this work over here we have a bunch of
giant tires terrible for your back but
great for Instagram this is our spa
wellness area perfect for rehab these
jets are okay free weights cable
machines and of course benchpress whoa
I'm in let's get started
nothing like an extra week to rehab
light reps for the normal players
meditation for Toms cold okay thanks
here's my special mind power Nicholas
come closer there's one thing I need you
to do for me you need me to win the
Super Bowl now just hand the ball off
and try not to lose points
how are you missing Nick you scored
seven TVs once I think I used up on my
touchdowns that game okay let's do some
footwork all right catch the bird it
always started sub dog did score zero
points last game going Nick Nick go up
the stairs like in the movie who's the
dovey no this is what I'm supposed to be
out here you know
you made it
welcome to the fail gate I don't get it
we have to go watch the teams that beat
us oh god no we drink a lot and try to
forget the postseason Oh hold up there's
a postseason I don't get it who are all
these excited people Jared these are
fans I've heard about that
do you have fans yeah I did hey Bills
fans look I hate tables too Nathan no
you do not have the coordination bills
mafia my
[Music]
tickets tickets just thousands of
tickets that we no longer need franchise
quarterback got your franchise
quarterback here anyone looking for a
franchise quarterback only thirty
million dollars yeah um I'm interested
coach come on we gotta go beat the Pats
not a catch Oh Yahoo it's a shotgun oh
hell yeah Mon hurry up in there
everybody falls
a presses were fighting and all sorts of
things but Tom Brady they call me the
goat like is this super coast gonna stop
us from getting off six people named
Nick Houck wait till I'm 60 I'm in
perfect health see science is fake so
please buy t b12 miss Graham and I love
eating belts pass me the ball I'm a
super hot air 2004 was the last time
they felt
my course in Seattle Park the earth will
now bow to the king
his Lords of the Rings
[Music]
I was gonna get a curse like the Red Sox
yeah girls love our deepest of long
[ __ ] yeah
once they golf flirts when I pass the
Hertz yeah don't you taste like dirt
Buster's Bob hurt you have to use that
we rush through the slideshow oh my they
want ballet drive drive it like it's hot
Eagle tea and we stopping all your plan
stop saying that our fares can't ugly
ruck come on Phileas the City of
Brotherly Love
[Music]
you
it's time choose your weapon carts of
Broncos I guess they have some weapons
but the general will the eatos destroy
grid iron Heights will all of the
marketable stars finally escape vir
who are you I'm David Johnson the number
one fantasy running back to 2016 what
will the Vikings do at quarterback
there's only one contract the Pens right
and you're injured beets will Blake
bortles Lee the XF fails Alabama
Americans to the super slam smack ball
where in the world is Andrew Luck are
you here for the arms deal this is gonna
be okay
we'll Pat Sherman be seduced by the Big
Apple and which quarterback will be
drafted into the upside Brown you're out
find out next season on gridiron Heights